[Applauso]
che cosa sono i tuoi valori il cui
valore essenziale fondamentale
stasera ti chiedo e voglio anche
condividere una storia mia siviero
cominciato alla nasa era un sogno da
piccola di essere scienziato alla nasa
wow il mio primo compito ed è di fare
una mappa per un son di speziale che va
a response
per esplorare giove ma in un po come
colombo quando è andata in america le
mappe non erano precisi anche la mia
avevo pochi dati magari vai dal da voler
un giorno ci stavo lì dava anche il
computer
sentite un po lontano di casa mi metto i
coordinate della terra però non l'ho
visto
l'avevo boy ingrandito da giove non ho
vista la mia pianeta avevo colorato blu
lampeggiando finalmente l'ha visto un
pixel e io
io sono o microbe su quel kicks non so
però mi è venuto questa crisi
esistenziale e ho dovuto lasciare tutto
lì sono uscita in giardino cercando un
albero sì sì sì sono attese sono che ce
la faccia ce la faccio il wigan quanto
sono piccola quanto sono insignificante
mi ha colpito poi ok sono tornate su un
giorno dopo giorno sono sono riuscita a
lavorare finché mi sono trovato in un
meeting dove ho potuto spiegare la mia
mappa quanto importanti a tutti gli
altri strumenti sul fondo e spaziale
oddio mi è venuto di nuovo scusa scusa
bagno a bagno per non sono andata al
bagno sono usciti di nuove cercare
l'albero e starista risulterà ok ok
ogni tanto
finiva questa angoscia e non sono
riuscito a gestirlo però sai quando i
mimi va beh quando sono i cio non c'era
nessuno mi veniva un po di vergogna ma
tutti hanno questa paura o solo io
sì qualcuno sa chi o questo problemi
mimì mi cacciano fuori che così faccio
come posso come d'armi
mannaggia quel giorno si stava un
ufficio e quando mi è venuto non avevo
tempo di uscire cercare un albero beh
sono mese per terra sotto la scrivania e
quel giorno lì è venuto col compagno di
uffici che non veniva mai prima di
pranzo è venuto al b con 6 coca cola è
così successo personalmente in contatto
una penna che che cosa cerchi ho perso
la mia significanza o cosa è sato e si
ma ti rendi conto di quanto siamo
piccoli eventi conti che ci sono 100
miliardi di galassie in questione verso
e sappiamo niente dice niente ma proprio
niente io sto mandando un soldo e
speziale in questo chi è netto e
sappiamo così poco 6 weinstein ha detto
non vediamo al mondo come vediamo il
mondo come siamo che cos'è che devo
imparare da me i valori essenziali in
qualche modo superano polarità magari la
mia insignificanza è anche una cosa
unico da giove ti guardo la mia terra e
100 miliardi e giga le si sa è sì siamo
incredibile viviamo grandeur viglia
ok sono andate avanti ho lavorato su
giove anche urne e marte
finalmente una bella carriera tutte le
famiglie accanto ai bambini un giorno
poi il successo di nuovo
andiamo trent'anni dopo il mio bambino
stava male
buongiorno l'altro entrata ospedale e
non sapevo cosa fare perché non capivo
niente di che
mi sono trovato di nuovo in quell'abisso
il mio bambino non è una macchina non è
un robot nemi anche un pianeta il mio
bambino e lì mi sono trovato davanti
questo buio non sapevo dove cominciare
però mi guardarsi negli occhi a dire
mamma aiutami mamma mamma aiutami a quel
punto
ok
devo farlo e mi sono cercato giorno dopo
giorno per capire che cosa di che così
soffriva e perché i medici non sanno
cosa fare la medicina non funziona e
finalmente ho trovato un'ipotesi una
cosa strana neanche convenzionale che
lui soffriva di un stretto cocco e
questi anticorpi hanno attraversato ed
entrare in sul cervello e hanno accusato
un'infiammazione ma nessuno mi credeva
però l'aveva guarita con una pena cina
un qualcosa è semplicissimo però in quel
buio in quell'abisso con il mio bambino
ho sentito anche urli di atri bambini ma
quanti soffrono di questa malattia e
nessuno sa come aiutarli soffrono li
quanti quanti bambini
possiamo vedere il mondo magari in 22 mo
di uno come nulla una meraviglia e
l'altro modo in cui tutto è una
meraviglia
quindi va bene organizzato una
conferenza medica evitato dottori
americani a venire in italia abbiamo
fatto questo conferenza grandissima e
sono venuto delegati di 23 paesi tutto
la piccola idea è diventato un movimento
io non sono dottore e questa sindrome
non è ancora confermato però ci sono
adesso tanti i dottori ci sono
interessanti e insieme lavoriamo a
cambiare un'idea che cosa io ho imparato
ho imparato che in qualsiasi momento
possiamo guidare la nostra vita con il
nostro valore essenziale non solo noi
manchi un progetto la scuola la famiglia
possiamo guardare la disponibilità con
la libertà la sicurezza con la curiosità
con la ventura è molto importante la
paura quando amore
stasera vi portò allo specchio può darvi
guarda la tua anima e chiede vi che cosi
sono il vostro valore essenziale
grazie
[Applauso]